les chroniqueurs attend de voir que la
nouvelle vous a pas échappé
si vous regardez un peu les médias s'il
bossait coton quoi voilà depuis quelques
jours au fait des cartons d'audience
pendant prés jeunes a décidé jeudi que
les faits sont têtus de me confier
dorénavant tous les prêts gêne c'est
quoi la merde non je leur disais que les
chiffres étaient déjà sur le prochain
les chiffres sont pas mal elles sont
même tu lacombe fait montre et tu vois
la combe de nantua et hélas ouais c'est
quand j'étais sortie de l'émission quand
ça descend là non concernant ses comptes
ressortent des missions donc tu vas
sortir dès maintenant s'est pas démentie
justement
hanouna aura là
il est jour comme matthew talayssat
hanouna
plus sexy qu'un chameau de djerba alma
il s'habille toujours comme thala non
aller d'un du 9 3 ils demandent des
guichetiers sens en direct
ils se mirent quant à régis marcheurs
on est en train de faire de la merde de
la merde on sera jamais jamais c'est ça
qu'ils vont faire
désir
[Applaudissements]
il est dans le canton
[Rires]
mais là c'est les vacances scolaires
alors j'adore donc là la chaussée c'est
les vacances scolaires premier jour de
vacances scolaires on est content 1
on sait qu'on a encore deux semaines
avant de faire les devoirs et il ya
toujours votre mère qui rentrent le soir
qui fait alors tu as commencé les
récents rappels et même si on sait qu'on
a deux semaines on s'y prend toujours le
dimensionner la veille
mais là on en train de travailler comme
des oufs comme ça et ont travaillé à ton
père karim idée alors tu aurais pas pu
tu prends un bain thermal avait sonné
mais moi je connais tous à 1 médaille ne
joue pas mais dis moi alors par qu'on
t'enlève tout de suite cette dernière a
laissé partie de l'émission jean coutu
les voir aller mal je vous dis ouais je
croyais pas ça ouais
j'étais persuadé du contraire et l'or et
quand j'ai vu et j'ai constaté ce truc
là non eh ben je me suis dit mais non
c'est une voiture de l'envol
non gt gt la gt faisait pas pardon
ajoute moi ça normal
son nom n'avait d'autre choix la
belgique soit normal c'est quoi ça passe
et non à sa taille normale et une touche
au cul ça va être dur attend c'est
normal ça normal
le but de l'endroit en direct s'il vous
plaît c'est le pré vous savez qu'on
apprenne la est-ce que quelle est ta
question pour les télés c'est là ma
question d'associer au de gainage moi
une culture sécu oui alors et battesti
vois tu pas ce nom sauf que tu mets ton
cul au réfrigérateur
soit tu verras tu mets ça de benaï bas
montre nous des squats moi ça va c'est
ça il faut faire ça ça c'est des fort
bien évidemment j'ai tous mes affaires
et cantonales connu le cul dur enfin on
sent tout de suite où c'est parti c'est
n'importe quoi bon les chéris déjà bravo
pour rien c'est magique mission bonifie
tout ce que j'aime parce que aujourd'hui
vous savez que c'est la grande finale de
ping pong la grande finale du big bang
qui sera commenté par philippe candeloro
et nelson
ce sera face à dominique
ouais unique sa poule qui t'a déjà battu
deux fois c'est pas de métier dit pas de
bêtise il m'appelait de bananes ananas
et moi qui ai fait moi qui c'est moi qui
ai gagné deux derniers matches vous
rappelle que c'est nous leur vie et qui
a gagné quelques champions je vous le
dis puis j'ai battu djokovic à un voile
à togoville numéro un mondial n'est pas
tout une bombe j'ai pleuré comme un
petit chien qu'on se calme on redescend
de deux étages
d'accord on va faire cette finale je
vous rappelle que dominique il avait
gagné et là il a il a gagné console de
jeux il a gagné
qu'est ce que c'est arrivé de merde
enfin bon là encore alors que manu un
bon alors c'est à taguer ni quoi déjà
alors une ps4
une pièce catway un voyage romantique i
way et notre estime et quoi avec moi et
droite n'ont nagl inégalé de l'été la
télé tu joues pour le vélo c'est çui là
bas sous là d'accord alors tu joues pour
le vélo électrique
écoute moi bien noble je t'explique si
tu perds tu perds tout tu perds le
voyage je récupère le voyage je récupère
la peste et la paix ces jeunes on m'a
dit que tu avais déjà ouvert la
playstation
tu as dix jours à la csn failli baisser
la garde au toit de la rame et koné bah
non mais là si tu veux la garder mais le
reste on joue tout de suite à émission
31 octobre halloween on est en direct on
est bien regardez il ya des retours un
bon whiting et me regarde comme ils
déboulent en quoi toi qui découle de
l'entente fois au joker et bébé on est
là pour s'amuser va manquer au système
quattro chéri ans marié aux mariés mais
marié ah oui quand-même un mariage
tim burton away ouvert le débat revient
quelques endroits 3,4 en diablesse ça
très bien toi pourquoi beetlejuice toi
t'es quoi toi en zombies à les toits par
titien et toi ça m'en fous ah ouais
black swan et toi t'en quoi toi jack
sparrow franchement et vous auriez pu
vous déguiser quand même très bien
je trouve que c'est léger vous attend
quoi londres accueille chaque année sur
dracula
vous vous êtes en quoi vous moi ça ça
fait peur ça ça fait peur ça c'est bien
j'attends je suis pas déguiser en fait
attend quoi pour toi
oui je suis homo et ben ça fait peur aux
gardes ça c'est dans la boîte